hat jetzt ein mensch wie sie hat er
schwächen ein typ ich sie hat er
schwächen und ich hatte eher schwächerer
natürlich hatte sprechen das hat ihr der
mann gewisse schwächen
ich bin ich für mich haben immer
empfunden dass die schwäche von mir dass
ich noch trocken blieb
was hat ein gewesener steiner nach 24
jahren nationaler politik über
verletzungen und den umgang mit selbigen
zu erzählen davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
die schöne fassade des bundeshauses
teusch ist auch bortoluzzi politik sei
weiß gott kein edles geschäft sondern
eines bei dem es normal sei dass einem
auch vermeintliche freunde in den rücken
fallen würden
man hat schafft und und versucht beste
lösung finden
und die stellen irgendwie kollege
michael stahl war wollte man eigentlich
nicht für möglich gehalten hat wie
vorher nie ja weil das nicht
diskussionspunkt sie sich orientieren
sich ist natürlich gewaltig gar nimmer
person bortoluzzi hatte einen
gesundheitspolitischen kompromiss namens
managed care mit ausgehandelt christoph
mörgeli und gregor rutz schwiegen lange
dazu und ließen ihn schließlich an einer
delegiertenversammlung ins offene messer
laufen
bortoluzzi wurde bestimmt ich glaube ja
ich war das nicht aber wenn ich verachte
alles noch schlimmer finde ich noch
schlimmer verachten weil er ehrlich ist
oder mit zuverlässigen
genauso wünsche er sich auch die
politische auseinandersetzung hart aber
fair und am ende wird man sich das
sägemehl vom rücken und reicht sich die
hand einfach aber kommen sie kann
[Musik]
wenn man bortoluzzi offen angeht
verträgt er einiges auch die frage wie
einer mit einem so stattlichen bauch und
einer vorliebe für ausgedehnte aproz ein
glaubwürdiger gesundheitspolitiker sein
wolle
da ist das auch die optimistische
landtage und weniger frauen draußen kann
ich sie nicht und somit mehr oder
weniger oder mehr oder missbrauchen
das wissenschaftlich erwiesen dass mini
wird zuschauen
[Musik]
täglich steigt bortoluzzi in den keller
seines hauses sind auch folter normal
bis hinab um die korrespondenz zu
erledigen er wird gehasst oder geliebt
dazwischen gibt es wenig und dann sind
da noch jene die ihn um hilfe bitten
etwa bei problemen mit der iv wenn so
sexy dessous zeigt war er doch dann ist
nur noch durch spiel gegen wer sich
einfach nicht so gut für die betroffenen
ist da muss man irgendwie haben
ausgerechnet er der 2003 wieder
christoph blocher den begriff schein
invalidität lancierte arena natürlich
wusste er als gesundheitspolitiker dass
die svp damit nur einen kleinen teil
eines komplexen problems gerecht wurde
trotzdem trommelte er an vorderster
front mit
und mann haben wir so einen als metro
finden damit man endlich aufrüttelt und
die entwicklung am morgen das ist straff
ist ganz auf sie ich finde das ganz
ehrlich und ich weise wie manche die
diskussion persönlich prof diese
verletzungen habe nicht er zu
verantworten
die svp sei quasi genötigt worden zu
diesem ton wobei ihm der zweihänder
schon auf liege sondern oper und das
glück zuteil der politik oder wollen sie
weinen aus über die ganzjahres wand
irgendwo muss die hsh sie noch unter 100
dollar
das gefällt der svp basis die partei
führt ihn 2002 gar zum
bundesratskandidaten er war chancenlos
markierte aber für die svp präsenz wie
schon bei seiner ständeratskandidatur
bitter wurde sind es als er 2005 in den
zürcher regierungsrat wollte diesmal
ernsthaft aber sogar in seiner
wohngemeinde wo er gemeindepräsident
gewesen war zogen die welt den cvp
kandidaten vor
es braucht einen wunderbar zynisch
leute die bortoluzzi kennen sagen diese
niederlage sei für ihn eine bittere
pille gewesen
bortoluzzi räumt ein dass in die
schlappe verletzt habe gleichzeitig
tröstet er sich damit dass sich sein
stammtisch darauf geeinigt habe dass er
eben keine sei der ein rückgrat wie ein
velo schlauch habe bevor die antwort
konnte ihre denn ist auch in form
gewesen
dort ist für mich eher als zeichen wenn
man hat nicht geweint weil ich hier bin
oder so und dann brechen will ich
reingekommen und das ist finde ich auch
gut für ein politisch aber es gibt
andere wendet sie müssen gefällt werden
wenn sie mir diese geworden bringe zwar
nicht aber sie sind wir bis in höhere
kunst
das ist zwar in der grenadiere es
seither sieht er sich als einen der
weitermacht auch wenn es weh tut immer
vorwärts er versteht das leben als
sportliche herausforderung und
vergleicht die politik gerne mit einem
fußballmatch
ich hoffe der innenverteidigung spielt
nämlich bürger verteilt haben und wer
hat ein gut gemachter mann
also ich mir eigentlich sie aber
mannschaft hat zur technik schossen
nicht unbedingt ein super so gut das
habe natürlich also in der politik sind
mir fremd
wir sind ganz wenig und mehr der
autoschau ami polizei nicht weiter viele
seiner songs eigentor dass er sich
weigerte vor ablauf der legislatur
zurückzutreten weil eine junge frau eine
juristin nach gerutscht wäre
was ist das problem die frau oder die
juristin beides für mich ist sie keine
ideale vertreterin der frauen gemeint
war barbara steinemann
mit dem etat der verbotenen zone mit
papieren gebiete zu verlassen
er lässt bei sich gerne mal fünf gerade
sein
seine partei ist als ein steinemann fall
weniger locker und zeigte dem gc fan
dafür die gelbe karte für die kommenden
wahlen ist die junge juristin nun auf
der nationalratsliste
[Musik]
von ihrer frau schwer verletzt worden
er tritt nach obwohl hinter gegenwind
nach seiner ersten attacke gegen
steinemann verletzt hat besonders dass
natalie rickli damals dem blick sagte es
reicht porto luzie müsse sich bewusst
werden was für die partei im hinblick
auf die nächsten wahlen das beste ist
für porto lucia nach frau natalie wie
kriegt die es wagte ihn indirekt zum
rücktritt aufzufordern ist in seinen
augen illoyal und zudem ein
leichtgewicht
die richtige und wichtige und unwichtige
ja auch wenn auch die ja dann auch
tragen das ist schon so wenn ich
vergesse kraft das was ich kriegen musst
du schon was sie weiß es gab an dass das
ist so dick wie zeit ist sein
seine wochenenden verbringt bortoluzzi
im glarnerland in seinem ferienhaus
seine frau ist aus allen hier sei die
welt noch in ordnung im gegensatz zur
stadt zürich anfang der achtzigerjahre
damals bei den sogenannten oberen haus
krawallen sehr politisiert worden
als migranten sohn der es dank harter
arbeit zu einer kleinen schreinerei
gebracht hatte hätten ihn die
respektlosen herren sünden vom
zürichberg entsetzt
die leute natürlich sagen wann bis wann
muss man am anfang mit den 200 jako der
spielwiese oder habe aber wenn schon
verbal und sich und sich mit und sich
damit ein anderer wind war es natürlich
noch den unterschied kommt gomobi noch
einen unterschied also wenn man sich mit
wort und und der demokratischen mitte
lebt ist es auch dieses soll mit den
anderen zusammen schlaf
die svp sei als einzige partei klar
gegen diesen mist gewesen wobei deren
eigentliche feindbilder freilich andere
sind und waren nämlich die fremden
früher zb die italiener
sind die denn ihre gene xiii zentimeter
sie hat das ok will mini familie
zusammen zieht also vielleicht stimmt
das nicht so das problem
mit der zahl der gastarbeiter stiegen
damals auch die spannungen der bundesrat
setzte gar eine kommission ein um die
probleme zu studieren
deren präsident waren die 1964 vor einer
weiteren zunahme des ausländeranteils
[Musik]
bei wir nun effektiv von einer
überfremdung bedroht sind
wir laufen gefahr dass wir unsere
schweizerische eigenart und
eigenständigkeit verlieren wenn jeder
der die zahl der ausländer noch weiter
zunehmen wird die frau komponente
fraktion die der mann der schott ohne
gestellt sie das ist und mentalität
politisch nicht so offen dass sie der
bearbeitung sowie dann hat man natürlich
dann völlig um das sehen ja ja aber
leider richtig gut sein dass der
verdiente kreieren oder auszuschreiben
die familie hat mich sogar auf 1 472
wassermann forscht jetzt warten wir
wollen generation für dich sind dann
fehlt um einzelne dienste via browser
integriert ja das ist nicht ausschließe
[Musik]
bortoluzzi hat vier kinder die familie
war ihm stets ein großes anliegen
jedenfalls politisch den eigenen
nachwuchs hat seine frau allerdings
mehrheitlich alleine großgezogen
familienpolitiker bortoluzzi war selten
zu hause
unterdessen hat sicherlich gemacht
die folgen sind dann plötzlich nur mit 7
so ist damit dass er so bist du dir will
ich werde sie unschön sind da und ich
glaube dass ich nicht genau
ich habe eine geschichte
wahrscheinlich ist ja darüber gemacht
und sind in führung gegangen die frau
zieht nicht das ist ja ganz japan
gemacht und die haben wir mit ca
ich habe sogar zum beispiel ja weil sie
zange komponiert es ist natürlich so
wenig konfliktpotenzial cauvin
zuständigkeiten natürlich nach alter
schule würde die einen sagen das ist so
wie sie ist verrußt zustand ich sie hat
vor allem driburger toni hatte betrieb
und der politik und da hat es wenig
konfliktpotenzial den antrieb steht noch
nicht fest
es sind die rolle messi einfach ist
diese aktuellen sms und er ist sehr
positiver mensch wo mir ab und zu mache
abgabe also wenn ich auf ihn ist sehr
viel profitiert die den pc
und er machte dank ihrer karriere
brachte es weiter bis auf geringe zu
bundesräten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
roger waters kürzlich und die nächste
alles mit freundinnen bortoluzzi hat ein
gewinnendes wesen gilt als verlässlich
und integer gleichzeitig ist der ein
hardliner der die heutige svp im engsten
machtzirkel und christoph blocher
maßgeblich mitgeprägt hat während mit
dem mit eurem engagement aus bayern
haben wir das ab und bot das ist ganz
alt hatten liberale und unternehmerisch
orientierten teile von der partei
eigentlich behandelt
nein zum ewr beitritt zum europäischen
wirtschaftsraum scheitert an volks- und
am ständemehr nach der abstimmung 1992
übernahmen blocher und sein syrischer
flügel das ruder in der svp unterhalten
fordern von sieg zu sieg
punkt blockes wahl in den bundesrat
tiefpunkt seine abwahl und die wahl von
eveline widmer schlumpf
wenig bitte mal nicht
das im gutachten dass ich sowieso nicht
so verkehrt
sehr schöner wohnen
ein abschied im eher christa sind es
nicht im gegenteil
in seiner jugend hatte er drei träume
einen dicken schlitten eine goldene uhr
und ein ferienhaus
all das hat er erreicht unter anderem
dank der politik
zudem wurde ein einflussreicher
strippenzieher lobbyisten suchen seine
nähe der economy seas und der
arbeitgeberverband und das zieht
johannesburg aber nichts nachsteht hat
den handelsstart konnten eignen wie vor
500 berufen sind der betrieb im landtag
antreten der 1
hier kommt der überall hv und kvg rieden
und besetzte damit eine nische
das ist faszinierend oder der politik
er hat das chemische gesellschaft
zwischen können mitreden macht augusta
bedeutung cyber zar das persönliche
befriedigung in stammheim als noch
schwierig zum zu machen
gesagt dass sie sagte wenig komponente
eines fehler der einfach gerne
politisierte ganz ohne auftrag geht nun
eines der letzten male von einer session
nach hause ich frage mich ist da
irgendwo doch das bewusstsein dass einer
wie er nicht unverletzt wurde sondern
auch verletzt hat etwa als er sich zur
vermutung verstieg homosexuelle hätten
einen hirn lappen der verkehrt läuft
[Musik]
stellen sie sich mal vor um 15 jährige
jungen bemerkt ich bin homosexuell mir
hat zudem stehe im elternhaus völlig
wieder kollegen unter bortoluzzi und
zeichner ja die halterin vertreten
glauben bei jaguar das ist werde ich für
so einen burschen konnten
er muss - raucht noch mal zu seiner
persönlichen eigenen staat
ich habe kollegen honig sehr kurz
verhältnis kommen und dem projekt in dem
zusammenhang dass man muss aber der
versuch der dunkelheit oder das sondern
ich glaube einfach gar nichts machen
ja was denn es ermöglicht überall kommt
mit dem 200
das ist auch wahr
was sagen die richtigen erreicht auch
wenn sie teurer verletzte er auf eine
oper verletzt hat damit frauen mit der
spd sagte das ist nicht ob sich das ist
es was der ksv mit 68 ist nun also
schluss mit oben
im wissen darum dass noch keiner
vermisst worden seien wären nur wenige
wirklich überragend auch schon christoph
blocher nachteil für uns ist groß -rufen
aus jetzt können wir den kaffee gekocht
[Musik]